- [Instructor] Let's say that
we have a polynomial, p of x,
and we can factor it,
and we can put it in the form
x minus one times x plus two
times x minus three times x plus four.
And what we are concerned with
are the zeros of this polynomial,
and you might say, "What
is a zero of a polynomial?"
Well, those are the x-values
that are going to make the
polynomial equal to zero.
So another way to think about it is,
for what x-values is p of x
going to be equal to zero,
or another way you can think about it is,
for what x-values is this expression
going to be equal to zero.
So for what x-values is x
minus one times x plus two
times x minus three times x plus four,
going to be equal to zero.
I encourage you to pause this video,
and think about that a little bit
before we work through it together.
Well the key realization here
is if you have the product
of a bunch of expressions,
if any one of them is equal to zero,
it doesn't matter what the others are,
because zero times anything else
is going to be equal to zero.
So the fancy term for that
is the zero product property.
But all it says is, hey,
if you can find an x-value
that makes any one of these
expressions equal to zero,
well that's going to make the
entire expression going to be,
it's going to make the entire
expression equal to zero.
So, the zeros of this polynomial
are gonna be the x-values
that could make x minus one equal to zero.
So x minus one equals zero.
Well we know what x-value
would make that happen,
if x is equal to one, if you
add one to both sides here,
x equals one, so x equals one
is a zero of this polynomial.
Another way to say that is
p of one when x equals one,
that whole polynomial is
going to be equal to zero.
How do I know that?
Well if I put a one in, right over here,
this expression right
over here, x minus one,
that is going to be equal to zero.
So you're gonna have zero
times a bunch of other stuff
which is going to be equal to zero.
And so by the same idea,
we can figure out what
the other zeros are.
What would make this part equal to zero?
What x-value would make
x plus two equal to zero?
Well, x equals negative
two, x equals negative two,
would make x plus two equal zero.
So x equals negative two is
another zero of this polynomial.
And we could keep going.
What would make x minus
three equal to zero?
Well if x is equal to three,
that would make x minus
three equal to zero,
and that would then make
the entire expression
equal to zero.
And then last but not least,
what would make x plus four equal to zero?
Well if x is equal to negative four.
And just like that
we have found four zeros
for this polynomial,
when x equals one the
polynomial's equal to zero,
when x equals negative two the
when x equals three the
polynomial's equal to zero,
and when x equals negative four
the polynomial's equal to zero.
And one of the interesting things
about the zeros of a polynomial
you could actually use
that to start to sketch out
what the graph might look like.
So, for example, we know,
that this polynomial
is going to take on the
value zero at these zeros.
So let me just draw a rough
sketch right over here.
So this is my x-axis, that's
my y-axis, that's my y-axis.
And so, let's see, at x equals one,
so let me just do it this way,
so we have one, two, three, and four.
Then you have negative one,
negative two, negative three,
and then last but not
least, negative four.
We know that this polynomial, p of x,
is going to be equal to
zero at x equals one.
So it's going to intersect
the x-axis right there.
It's going to be equal to
zero at x equals negative two,
so right over there.
At x equals three, right over there.
And x equals negative four.
Now we don't know exactly
what the graph looks like,
just based on this.
We could try out some values
on either side to figure out,
hey, is it above the
x-axis, or below the x-axis,
for x-values less than negative four.
And we can try things out like that
but we know it intersects
the x-axis at these points.
So it might look something like this,
this is a very rough sketch.
It might look something like this,
we don't know without doing
a little bit more work.
But ahead of time, I took a
look at what this looks like,
I went on to Desmos, and I graphed it,
and you can see, it looks
exactly as what we would expect.
The graph of this polynomial
intersects the x-axis
at x equals negative four,
actually let me color code it,
x equals negative four,
and that is that zero right over there,
x equals negative two,
that's this zero right there,
x equals one, right over there,
and then x equals three, right over there.
In future videos we will
study this in even more depth.